yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights visit
expressvpn.com
yang
at this point i think a significant
proportion of americans get their
information from comedy shows
it's like comedians that become like the
next generation truth-tellers
i i think so which is
in a lot of ways unfortunate because
it's not really the purpose
of of comedy and
the fact that we don't have enough
trusted sources of information
is what is hurting our democracy and i
think we feel it even in
places that we do trust that they hold
back and i i've been on those news
programs as a subject
and sometimes that like the questions
get
hashed out and vetted and pre-approved
before you agree to show up so there's
that yes
you could be like hey look don't ask me
about x and y but number two if your
goal is to
get out of that interview um
saying nothing like you can do it
you just don't answer the question i do
it in movie interviews people
ask something and if i don't have an
answer for it i just say anything
and then they're basically out of time
yeah you can run at the clock on those
interviews
all the time
[Music]
i am thrilled to welcome the yang speaks
the
prolific powerhouse comedian
writer director producer half the things
that
have been in movie theaters uh that that
had the
word comedy after them over the last
number of years uh from this man judd
apatow judd welcome to
yang speaks it's so good to see you i'm
happy to be here
in this in this room look look at this
the glamour
[Laughter]
um well i saw the king of staten island
which was your latest work and enjoyed
it immensely and i appreciated the fact
that you made it available
um in june or in quarantine or video on
demand because i know there might have
been some calculation
on that but it was heartfelt
it was funny it was very very human um
certainly for me
like it was sort of a struggle i think
the description was something like this
is pete davidson's life if he hadn't
discovered comedy something along
those lines that like that's one way to
look at it yes
yeah but would love to uh hear your take
on
um on that project particularly because
like i felt like it was very
uh intimate like i feel like at this
point you could do anything under the
sun but you chose a very human story to
tell
i think that i'm attracted to just
stories which reflect
how hard it is to be a human being in
general
so my instinct is always for the stories
to
not have a lot of you know fireworks
villains science fiction i love all
those movies but
i definitely think days are hard to get
through i think that's what we're all
realizing like it's it's hard to just be
a person and try to connect with people
to try to be mentally
healthy to try to achieve your your
goals and evolve
and so when when someone has a good
story
about that that tends to be what i want
to talk about and i'm sure it's just a
projection of
my own pain and suffering you know of
how i see
you know my my emotional experience you
know pete's been through more than
most people less than some
in terms of having a very unique life
uh you know a specific kind of pain
around
losing a parent during a national
tragedy uh
his father was a firefighter who died on
9 11.
and i think that it shaped him
in a lot of ways and that's what he
wants to explore
in the movie you know what what does it
do to a family when you lose a parent
and you lose
the parent who dies while committing a
heroic act
and all the ways that complicates
somebody's
childhood and it was a comedy anyone
listening to this and watching this it
wasn't
it's hilarious doesn't it sound
hilarious
yeah we're making it sound a little bit
morose but it was really funny
pete's very funny uh bill burr is
hysterical like they're
like i feel like marissa tomei is like
everybody's
uh mom or aunt
because she was i think she was aunt bae
in a couple of spiderman movies
but one of the things i got from the
movie too
and this has been consistent throughout
your career is that like that you're
trying to sort of help
the next generation of uh storyteller
comedian
along and tell their stories and the
first
very first guest on yang speaks was ken
jong who obviously is incredibly
grateful
to you that talked about how you were
one of the main reasons why he went into
a county full-time because
you saw in him you were like hey you can
really do this
um and i feel like while ken has that
story i have a feeling there are dozens
of other people that have had a similar
story where you've
helped you like you go around like
knighting people
that after they've been knighted by you
that they go off to have these
incredibly productive careers well ken
is someone that we met when we were
casting knocked up
and you know we had this very unique
experience that we've talked about
which was we went to see a doctor
when we were searching for somebody to
uh be the
ob gyn at uh our baby's birth
and we met a few people and we chose
somebody and that person on the night
that uh our daughter was being born
left town and didn't tell us and didn't
set us up with a backup situation no
they just went to you know a bar mitzvah
up north and bailed on us and when when
we called
to say you know what what are we
supposed to do
uh try to you know connect us with
another doctor
who we had never met yeah that's not
cool
and sometimes i think the universe does
this to you on purpose because we were
obsessed with finding a doctor who would
not bail on us
we talked about it all the time we would
like the doctor we see
to deliver the baby we don't want to
meet someone and then have someone else
in the
office was this your first or second
child or
this was our second child and so that
was
very important and and we said are you
going to be there
absolutely going to be there and
so when that happened
when my wife uh went into labor we
had to find the doctor we literally
didn't have a doctor and we said we
don't want your back up we were just
very upset with the
office and how it was handled so we
wound up
calling a doctor that we did not
ask to be the doctor and so it was sort
of like the runner up
exactly it was it was a runner-up
who must have felt rejected in some way
but
uh like congratulations
know we didn't choose you but we
desperately need your help right now
meet us at the office right now and it's
also it's also
you know it's a it's an all-night uh you
know affair
so this this doctor agrees
to come and it's just really
grumpy and unpleasant
and borderline mean
to us and at the time it was a nightmare
really was
a terrible moment and
you know i think we've all had that with
doctors where some doctors are great and
very in tune with you emotionally
and other doctors who might be great
doctors they're completely out of tune
with you emotionally and and
and they don't almost understand your
feelings
so this doctor was so
rough on us uh
and he did say the line
when i said you know thank you for
coming said yeah i was just sleeping
[Laughter]
um but at some point i took him in the
hallway
to say you need to be nicer this is
really too hard
uh uh on on us and
while i was saying it my stomach gurgled
like
and it was like i was gonna just crap
myself
you know in the middle of the hallway at
the hospital and the doctor
heard it and i saw in his eyes him
realize in that moment i'm being mean to
these people
like this guy's cracking and it's my
fault and he did try to make an
adjustment
from hearing my stomach make a sound
you're metabolically destroyed exactly
i almost [ __ ] the hallway
and so i you know as a writer there's
always a part of your brain that's
thinking this is
terrible but it's also hysterical
if we can get through this night uh in a
healthy
uh normal way if he could be nice us at
some point this is a funny story
and i think that's the great thing about
being in comedy is when things are
terrible
they're not just terrible they're they
also might have some value
you're you're like that this terrible
experience is somehow productive for my
career
exactly and that's what that's what
happens like i threw out the first game
in the first pitch in a mets game
i was thinking about this because you
know fauci had a bad throw the other day
and i had a bad throw but before i did
the throw i thought
well if it goes bad at least it's a
pretty funny story tell people
of this humiliating first pitch
experience
so when we were looking for someone to
play that doctor
it was a hard thing to find you know
people who aren't doctors were not very
good at
getting across the energy of stressed
out doctors and ken came in
and the and our casting director allison
jones is a genius
who did the office and a zillion of our
movies
she said you know he's fantastic he's
exactly right
and he came in and he just captured that
quality and he found a way to make it
really funny too where you believed he
was a real doctor because he is
but he he knew how doctors are
badly behaved around patients but the
thing that we did that was really funny
is we kept shooting
extras for our our dvd and so whenever
we would shoot a scene we would say
let's just shoot a funny sketch
while we're here and a lot of times we
would shoot it on film we would just
roll the cameras and do something weird
for the dvd
and we just asked him to come in and be
really vicious
uh to catherine heigl uh who was in
character
as a so she's in bed pregnant and we
just had ken
scream at her like a doctor who had you
know
lost his mind and he did this like eight
minute rant
yelling at her and it's on the dvd it
was so funny that we thought
oh this guy is ridiculously talented and
hilarious it was all an improv
and he worked on other projects with us
and i'm so happy that his career has
gone well because he's like i think i'm
gonna
stop being a doctor and i'm like are you
sure
ken i mean
you never want anybody to quit their
vocation
you know can't you do it at the same
time i mean i knew he was funny but you
never know people find the parts
that show off how great they are there's
plenty of talented people
and it just doesn't line up they you
know they don't
have that magic moment where
they audition for something that they're
right for and the
director gets that they are right i mean
that happens
uh i knew i would want to work with him
so i'm so happy that he's turned
it into this gigantic career and he's
the nicest man
so yeah he's a really good guy
[Music]
you know what we need more than ever
right now freaking mail
you know so many people are at home
just living remotely working remotely
and you need to send stuff you need to
receive stuff
the post office is a vital public good
and people who think that it needs to
necessarily make money
uh are off base and how the heck do you
mail stuff
and avoid a trip to the post office
stamps.com is what we used on the
campaign trail and it's tremendous
you get like a digital post office on
your computer
the comfort of your own home or office
you can print postage
you can make it happen straight from the
computer you save time and money
and right now listeners get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage
and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment
this is not a scale that you can jump on
yourself but it will weigh just about
anything you're gonna mail
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in yang that's stamps.com
and then enter yang
[Applause]
i'd love to dig into what you just said
about how they're a lot of talented
people but then circumstances have to
break right they need the right role
they need
someone to see that they're the right
fit i mean because you you grounded out
your first love was stand-up comedy and
you grounded out in like
you know like the the grimiest of ways
where i think you started out as
literally like a
like a like dishwasher or busboy at a
comedy club in in new york
uh and uh you're like the alpha comedy
nerd now but i know like the beginnings
of like that that arc where you're just
like hanging out in clubs
with folks uh you know it's um
there are like a lot of people who come
and go and then some obviously become
huge stars like some like
uh some of the people that you've been
continuing to work with but then there
are a lot of talented people that
like you know this like disappeared in
terms of public consciousness because
um you know like of any of a number of
reasons
and one thing that i'm always fascinated
with is like how much
of any system so let's say the
entertainment industry
uh it is like what you'd call a quote
unquote like a meritocracy where if
someone's like really talented
like they're going to wind up having
like a certain degree of success
if they have the right qualities and how
much of it is circumstance find the
right people
find the right partners if you don't
have the right like co-writer or the
right casting director
like are there like a multitude of
really really talented people
that you came up with or saw but then
they didn't have the same level of
success as you might have projected
you know 15 20 years ago a lot of it
depends on
the definition of success
you know for some people it's just can i
not get a real
job can i be a comedian can i
you know pay my bills doing the thing
that makes me
happy for a lot of people that is the
success of it you know
which is like doing the work is itself a
victory like in a lot of these fields
yeah i mean in stand-up comedy if you
can make your living traveling around
the country and doing stand-up and
and you can avoid a type of job you
don't want to do for a lot of people
that is
enough and for some people they want to
write and direct movies and be
actors or actresses and they want a much
larger scale
success and different people chase
different things
there's always been people in comedy
that comedy people think oh that's the
best person
but for whatever reason maybe they're
not commercial maybe for some reason
they're not palatable to the masses
but it might be the comedian that
everyone runs in to watch that the
comedians run in to watch
because they're better than everyone
else but maybe it's edgier or maybe it's
it's stranger than what would be a
mainstream successful act
the comedian's comedian are there like a
few comedians comedians
out there that they're like oh we all
love this person
yes and there are those people that are
uh clearly funnier than everybody else
and maybe they don't want to be a star
maybe they love
you know the the size of their career
you know there's not that many people
who
um you know are the best of all time and
the world rejects them i mean it
usually if you really are that special
person
if you know if you're if you're dave
chappelle
or if you're amy schumer it's going to
happen for you it's usually
pretty clear who is a cut above
just like you know you know in in sports
it's it's just going to
happen but there are also people that
don't work well with others you know
they're like really talented
but they don't like to collaborate or
maybe the reason why they're so great
is because they're they're rebellious
and they have an oppositional stance and
they can't fit into
the system to make movies or have a tv
show because they don't know how to work
it
and that's what's very rare are people
who have
the talent and the charisma and they
understand how to work
the business sometimes you're funny
because you don't play well with others
yes and you you can't figure it out and
i
i know the first 10 years of my career i
was very argumentative and
i didn't know how to take notes and i
didn't know how to collaborate
in a healthy way and i i would
you know get in big big fights with
people because i was so protective of
the work
i didn't want to ever screw up the work
so if someone had bad notes
i was not pleasant to them you you were
like a capital c
creative judd you were like don't you
see the genius of freaks and geeks come
on people come on network
well that's a pain i'll ride this train
i mean that's like a
you know it's a painful situation people
have it in all businesses but when you
feel
very confident that what you're doing is
good
and the person who has power over you
says i don't think what you're doing is
any good
well that's you know that's when you
really go to war with somebody
and you have to decide well am i going
to water it down to please this person
that doesn't get it
or am i going to fight to make it
exactly what we all
in the collaboration want it to be and
you know over time i realized that the
key to it
is finding people who get what you do
you know when you're young you'll work
for anyone that will give you a job
or will pay for your tv show or movie
but if you get
any level of success you can say i need
to have that person
really understand what i do deeply so
the collaboration is healthy
and that's what i've been lucky enough
to do
later in my career is go oh universal
studios
they get what i do they get my sense of
humor they understand
at this point you've made some so many
people so much money man they could be
like well i don't get it but
but here you go but you'd be surprised i
mean i go out with like a tv show to
pitch a show
i still get rejected by most people i
don't really get that
you know you've succeeded so we trust
you
thing yeah i i a fair amount of the time
it literally means
nothing and that's you'd be surprised
how often
your uh rate of success does that factor
in
to the discussion about whether or not i
should be allowed to make
something that's fascinating you know
there are actually uncanny parallels to
what you just described
between uh let's say comedy and like
producing tv shows and movies
uh in terms of this corporate lair of
people and they have notes for you
and my experience with politics so let's
say that
you're a person running for president
you're like okay here's like the message
or here's how i'm actually going to say
something
and then you have this layer of people
who are professionals and do it for a
living
and like they're you know consultants
are like hey instead of saying it this
way you might want to say it this way
you might want to say it that way
and then like that there's like a part
of you that's like well
screw you like you know who who the hell
are you you know like i'm like the
author of this message so to speak sure
uh and
and then but so that but they have a
version of experience because they've
been through like multiple
uh in the in their case um campaigns in
your case they've made lots of like tv
shows and movies you get like the
equivalent of notes
and one of the things i think that's
happened in both entertainment
and politics is that that consultant
class in politics
very very uh influential
and if you were a new candidate you feel
like you you're like well they're the
more experienced hands like they've seen
this stuff so you like take it to heart
in my case i was like something of a
blend between young judd and like more
experienced judd where i was like okay
like i'll take your notes but if i
disagree with it i'm gonna ignore it
um and in part because with my campaign
we reached a certain level
of critical mass without any consultants
and then as soon as there was money
involved and the consultant showed up
that he had to think about it too much
right
but but it is funny it's like there's
almost like this corporate lair like
sanding down
certainly our political messaging
because i you know like i seen it happen
other candidates where like the
consultant class shows up and then all
of a sudden like you you see them
communicating in a certain way
well you could lose a sense of what
you're who you are
and that uh i think is very uh
similar i remember one of the first
things i did is i
i created a sketch show with ben stiller
the ben
stiller show which was on fox in 1992
and we shot the pilot
and i gave the pilot to two friends to
get
notes one was gary schaeling and one was
albert brooks
and then i did long calls with each one
about which sketches they liked
there were seven sketches on the pilot
and which ones they liked last
it was the exact opposite they
both chose different sketches now if i
took notes from either of them
we might have changed the pilot based on
their
preferences oh that's a better sketch
maybe that should be the first sketch
but it was all the opposite they just
like completely different
things on the pilot
and it was a giant lesson for me because
if i gave it to just one of them i might
have just taken all the notes
but i realized that i could have two
people that i look up to
that i think are at the very height
of of what they do that they both have
completely different opinions and they
both can be right
in a way you know who you know who's to
say how you interpret that so
what does that mean well that means that
we have to
go with our gut about it that we're not
going to get those clear answers and you
can get thrown off of your vision like
on freaks and geeks
the note to paul feig and i was these
kids need more victories
and our feeling was this show is about
the fact that they don't have victories
most of the time that
it's about friendship it's about their
struggles
to figure out who they are through this
process of high school which is really
hard on them
but if i if i took the note and gave
them more victories
maybe the show would have gotten picked
up and then maybe the second season
would have been terrible
and maybe we would have we would have
just lost our way and i think a
politician can do that as well
and we see it in history where we go
was clinton tough on crime
because it's a great way to run for
office
it's a great way to get supporters you
know you know were they against
uh you know gays in the military
uh because at that time
he you know with don't ask don't tell
that was a a political way of not of
offending people he wanted to vote for
him how many times did the consulting
class
make him change
his own views what he would he believe
i'm not sure what he believes i'm just
saying
we feel that all the time you know i
remember someone was saying the only
reason why
trump said build the wall was because
they wanted him to talk about
immigration a lot and he would forget
he wouldn't mention immigration
sometimes and they came up with this
concept of
saying build the wall and having the
crowd chant it
it was only created to make him remember
to talk about immigration
it wasn't like the people who thought of
it said we want him to actually build a
wall
it was just like a speech device this is
a way we're gonna make sure he can
remember this talking point
uh and especially if people then start
chanting it
uh that sounds very true to life given
what we know about
um trump and and the way his mind works
[Music]
at yang speaks we think that our data
should be ours and the fact is right now
your internet service provider knows and
tracks every single website you visit
what's worse is they can sell that
information to tech giants and data
brokers who then use
that data to target ads at you
expressvpn is one way to put a stop to
this it creates
a secure tunnel between you and the
internet so that your
activity can't be seen by anyone it's
like you magically remote in
on a computer that's located someplace
far far away totally anonymous
expressvpn is used by high-end companies
all the time
it's the world's number one rated
virtual private network by
cnet wired the verge and countless
others
so if you're like me and believe that
your online activity
is yours and yours alone secure yourself
by visiting expressvpn.com
yang today and use my exclusive link
expresssvpn.com
yang and you can get an extra three
months for free
that's expressvpn.com
[Applause]
[Music]
uh no and we're gonna get into politics
in a bit because i know you've been very
very
um active and passionate uh um on on
many levels uh
you clearly care deeply about live
comedy comedy i mean it you know it's
something where you yourself just went
back to
perform even though at that point like
you know you didn't necessarily need to
put yourself
to the uh you know i was talking to
michelle wolf
on the podcast a number of weeks ago and
we're talking about
what the heck live comedy looks like in
uh time of covid right now
and michelle right now is performing not
right now as we're talking but right now
is before we get a
cornfield in ohio um because she's
you know it's open air so it's very very
safe
um and i was joking with
someone that that cornfield in ohio is
now like the live comedy capital of the
that's right
of the country because it's her and dave
chappelle i think michael che has been
out there and so
if you happen to live with that part of
ohio you go
um but but it does strike me that if you
were to make
a short list of things that are going to
be the most
jeopardized by this climate live comedy
would have to be
toward the top of the list uh because
it's such an interactive
medium it's like you you know you you
can't really uh
figure out what's going on without some
kind of crowd feedback
uh and crowds are at this point
inadvisable especially indoor crowds i
mean it's one reason why they're doing
this outdoors in a corn field
i i think that it's it's a real tragedy
for us in
stand-up comedy uh you know we
we feel so bad for all the club owners
all the employees of
all these clubs hundreds of clubs and
venues and there are so many
uh you know comedians that work very
hard i mean we know
the mega famous people but there's also
you know hundreds or you know a thousand
other just hard-working really nice
funny people who spend
you know their entire lives trying to
make people happy trying to make people
laugh and it's a hard life you really
travel a ton
and and you're up late at night and
and you're you know constantly trying to
revise your act to make it stronger to
try to get ahead
if you have a family it it it can be
very very challenging
to be around because it is a life of
traveling
and that whole world has disappeared for
the most part i know there are some
places in certain parts of the country
that have
found a way to to put on shows with
you know limited crowds and you know
dave chappelle is obviously doing
something very
you know unique uh where he lives which
is fantastic
but most of that business is in
you know purgatory right now it's just
frozen and and we worry about all those
people i
have a lot of friends they they they
performed every night for decades i mean
there's the financial aspect there's
just the emotional aspect these people's
lives are about being creative and
expressing themselves and to take that
away from them
it must be you know very difficult on
their mental health yeah it makes me
really sad too
uh and you know you think about all the
people that are impacted i mean
the performers themselves but then like
all the bartenders and
the like the folks who work at these
clubs and these clubs are not
exactly like swimming in riches even in
good times
you know it's like like a lot of the
people who are in
uh in comedy just do it for the love uh
and it it breaks my heart that so many
people now are just going to be
um really cut adrift uh both financially
creative creatively i'm a huge fan of
uh of comedy in general like i think
it's really important and one of the
things that we're raising and now we're
going to sort of
move towards like the comedy politics uh
overlap is that at this point i think a
significant proportion of americans get
their information from comedy shows
it's like comedians that become like the
next generation truth-tellers
you have these politicians that now at
this point people don't trust very much
and then you have like the filter of the
news media
which unfortunately now also many
americans don't trust that much and you
have that like the sense of polarization
uh and then comedians are saying things
that make us laugh
but often there's like massive massive
amounts of truth in the jokes that
they're they're telling
um i think it's one reason why uh people
are gravitating towards people like dave
chappelle
as almost like the the uh the people who
can tell us what's going on
i i think so which is
in a lot of ways unfortunate because
it's not really the purpose
of of comedy i mean comedy should be a
part of it
it's part of the information ecosystem
but when it becomes your primary source
of information that's scary as well
and the fact that we don't have enough
trusted sources of information
is what is hurting our democracy and i
think we feel it even in
places that we do trust that they hold
back you know when you watch all the
sunday morning programs and
they interview you know the chief of
staff for
the president they they go soft on
everybody because they do want access
they do want them to come back
and you feel like wow these interviews
should all be way tougher
i mean we are in crisis mode and how
many times i watch it
someone in politics get interviewed and
i think
wow that was a pretty easy interview for
that person at a moment when tens of
thousands of people are dying based on
these
decisions and i think people like comedy
because the comedians don't
you know they don't have the access to
interview everybody everyone but they
don't have to put on that filter of
being full of [ __ ]
they don't have to be sweet about it
they could just say
this is madness this is hypocrisy this
is corruption
in the way you know a lot of journalists
want to uh but i don't think they can
say it in the same
term yeah journalists can't just throw
down that way because it somehow makes
them seem reactive
or biased which to me i mean at this
point like you said if you don't have a
strong point of view you're not
being awake or truthful and i've been on
those news programs as a subject
and i can say very much that if you were
let's say
a government official and you were put
on the spot in these interviews one to
your point they'll probably go somewhat
easy on you if you're in a
position of influence and sometimes that
like the questions get hashed out and
vetted and pre-approved before you agree
to show up
so there's that yes you could be like
hey look don't ask me about x and y
and the audience doesn't know that by
the way
doesn't know but but that's a giant
thing for the audience not to know
that you know going on these sunday
shows or
in certain interviews is the same as you
know me going on the tonight show
that there's a pre-interview and that
they're not going to come on if you're
going to
ask about russian bounties or or
something else and that that's the only
way they will come on
so it's filtered in ways that are not
transparent
to people because i you know it's
it's like the world has turned and
the news can't seem to adjust to it so
for instance
there's clearly a moment where you know
when donald trump said we have 15 cases
and it's going to go down to zero
we we know for sure that someone
privately said to
the president it's not going to zero
it's going to be hundreds of thousands
soon
and he made a political calculation not
to tell the country
and to not be honest about what we were
in for
and he set the conditions for what led
to tens of thousands of additional
people
dying who wouldn't have if at that
moment
he prepared and prepared the country
now can a journalist say that directly
which is you chose your political career
over the lives of thousands of people
and you are responsible for that
because in this meeting you were told
how this was probably going to progress
and you won't see people be that tough
on them
i've never heard anyone say to the
people around the president
when was he told this was going to get
out of control
what day did someone say it's not going
to be 15
it's going to be millions or tens of
thousands
and what did he say what did he say
and why did his messaging not change for
weeks and weeks and weeks or months
and that is the the question for this
election when was the president told
what was going to happen
and why did he reject that and why did
he not tell the country
well the second thing i'd say about
these interviews judd is that
if you are let's say a government
official
number one there's the certain types of
questions you might get asked but number
two if your goal is to
get out of that interview um
saying nothing like you can do it
you just don't answer the question i do
it in movie interviews people
ask something and if i don't have an
answer for it i just say anything
i mean that's the funny thing about
interviews you know people could say uh
you know what's it like uh you know
working with this actor
so you know what here's the great thing
about working in new york
you know what i mean like
totally we're now wondering which actor
you do not want to talk about what it's
really like to work with them
but but yes it's exactly like that judd
where what happens with if you were an
official and you didn't have to do this
when you were
talking about your movies but if you're
an official
let's say you have a six minute
interview segment what they do is they
sit the official down and they say here
are six minutes of talking points
and if they ask a question that uh is
not comfortable for you just go to
this you will then fill up the interview
time and it's over
uh yeah like like that that's the way it
works uh where
um so it's comical by the way if you
watch it
and you see someone you know talking to
kellyanne conway
and they ask a direct question and then
she says you know what we should be
talking about
is why you guys keep talking about blah
blah and sometimes the journalists will
go i hear what you're saying
but can you please answer this question
she'll do it again
she'll do it a third time and then
they're basically out of time
yeah you can run at the clock on those
interviews all the time because it's
just like the cadence of the tv
um format really where
and i've been in the format you know now
obviously like hundreds of times
and uh most of the time when i was
running i was like i'm trying to get
this message out
um but sometimes they'd ask me about
something that i had no interest in
talking about
my propensity is just to answer the
question you asked me a question i'll
probably try to answer it
but there were there were some times
when it was like
um you know some something like along
the lines of what you're saying it's
like you asked
asked about like an actor uh working
with them and you're like i'd rather not
talk about this so they could go
someplace else
that's why representative katie porter
should be the person on all these shows
interviewing everybody
because when you see you see her uh you
know speak to people
she was talking to the head of lockheed
the other day yeah she's tough
she's she's smart and um she was saying
why are you applying for
uh ppp or whatever for help
she's like you made 15 more this year
than the year before and he's like
everyone's asking for help
and she's like yeah that doesn't make it
right why are you asking for help
and you know he and he dances around it
but she just keeps doing it and i think
a lot of our congress people
have found a way to prepare for those
moments in a much
tougher way than we've ever seen before
and we need to see more of that i mean
you know that chris wallace interview
the other day with donald trump was
fascinating
because he he went harder than we've
seen
most people go to say no that's not
true what you're saying and
donald trump is clearly shocked that
anybody's like no i have the information
what you're saying is not correct and we
really need that from
everybody because obviously everyone
should always tell the truth
but these questions
cost tens of thousands
of lives and for some reason it's like
everything's been so
normalized and republicans they want to
normalize
death they want to normalize this so
that we all go
well it was only 380 000 people
when really maybe it could have been
25 000 for the whole country they want
us to think it's
fine and it isn't fine and it is a
political calculation
to time out what happens with this
pandemic to get reelected as opposed to
just do what
[Music]
helps
[Music]
here at yank speaks we are big believers
in taking care of ourselves
and also taking care of your mental
health now sometimes taking care of your
mental health is not possible in the
sense that you can't just
figure it out for yourself without some
help
and if you want some help there's help
available at better help which is a
digital
counseling service it's like 21st
century therapy
you connect from the comfort of your own
home can start communicating in under 24
hours and you get professional
counseling
at your fingertips totally confidential
you can unload and unlock some of the
things that are weighing you
down the fact is right now we're all
struggling this is a mental health
crisis and catastrophe but one way you
can
make it through is to actually get help
and the way to get better help
is just to go to betterhelp.com
yang you'll get 10 off your first month
over 1 million people have already
started taking charge of their mental
health with better help
again that's betterhelp help dot com
slash yang and i will say that help can
be a variety of things so that's
depression or stress anxiety but also
relationships
sleeping trauma you're just angry i'm
angry all the time
in quarantine family conflicts grief
self-esteem literally
there's the whole it runs the gamut here
at betterhelp so it's betterhelp.com
that's helpbetterhelp.com
[Music]
when we were talking you and i about
politics a little while ago you said
something that i thought was very
interesting
which was that generally speaking like
the um the funnier candidate
will prevail when you're talking about
something like sadly that's one of my
theories
yeah one of your theories uh and then
you suggested something really
interesting to me which was like
where you which was like you were
thinking maybe we should try and uh
now the dynamic of this particular
action now completely changed like in my
opinion
joe you know is uh heavily favored in
the polls now and we're in the midst of
a crisis and so like the
humor test like at this point everyone's
like screw that like i'd rather just
like return to sanity
but there was a uh but
there was a suggestion you had that i
thought was really interesting you were
like maybe we should get some comedy
writers together to like write some
um some good scripts or lines for
uh whoever the democratic nominee like
uh you know like uh
like uh may end up being and i i mean
obviously we're in a different moment
now but i thought that there was
something really
powerful to like your uh your general
thinking on it um
which is that at this point politicians
are communicators um and there's like
certain language they use to communicate
uh you know that is hitting with certain
groups of americans like maybe less so
for for others
but i was part of these debates uh judd
and it was clear to me that that some of
the candidates definitely had jokes that
they'd rehearsed
but they they certainly had stuff that
they'd like practiced sure
and we do have these debates upcoming
between
joe and donald trump that may be
one of the only uh
set of events that could potentially
even change the dynamic of the race
meaningfully
i i think that you know
in america unfortunately
so much of it is entertainment and
people are taken in by
charisma sense of humor attractiveness
and a lot of the presidents from the
past that maybe had
you know were not appealing to look at
or listen to but who happened to be
brilliant
uh maybe some of those people would not
be elected today you know there are a
lot of people who are
incredible at their jobs who are really
uh not
pleasant to talk to or or look at
they're not funny
but maybe they're just amazing at making
the correct choices or thoughtful
difficult choices and if you look back i
i joke about this but i do think it's
true you tend to see that the slightly
more
entertaining or warmer candidate often
wins i i mean when al gore lost
i remember being pretty shocked because
when you watched the debates
you know george bush was terrible in
those in those debates
but he did have a certain charm about
him and the country was doing great at
that moment the economy was
he was very strong i have a beer with
competition i remember that
and and it was almost like the the
country had
you know a clinton fatigue a scandal
fatigue
and they weren't factoring in the fact
that the country was operating
in in you know for our country uh
pretty well the economy was doing very
well it wasn't the moment to toss out
the democrats but
a bored country is seeking
entertainment and a friend and
and and and i think that that has
happened many times in our in our
history where
we're attracted to that and i think you
might say the same thing about donald
trump where
he's more of an aggressive insult comic
um
and people didn't pay attention to the
fact that he had ripped off a lot of
students that he didn't pay his bills
that he was uh you know awful to women
you know there were so many very clear
signals to us that he was corrupt and
not empathetic
and a dangerous person but people bought
into
you know his bravado his entertainment
factor
and he had no record so it was easy for
him to say
hillary clinton is corrupt because he
hadn't held any
elective office he didn't have to come
through on any of his promises i think
if you look at what
what happened he he really didn't
accomplish any of the things that he was
talking about yeah what you're saying is
spot on judd and this is one of like the
great dynamics that i'm scratching my
head about
um into some level with concern um which
is that it seems like politics and
entertainment have
uh have merged and at least in some
respects
and then if you have some larger than
life uh figure that
millions of americans in the case of
donald trump felt like they knew from
the apprentice and other things then
like he like overrode um
a lot of other like the rest of the
republican field and then him against
hillary he seemed somehow more
entertaining and appealing and
like quote unquote authentic sure and in
the democratic field too there was
something that happened and i was the
beneficiary of this so it's
not a knock but like let's say you have
folks like steve bullock governor of
montana who makes a late entrance into
the race
or michael bennett senator from colorado
who like people didn't find particularly
like exciting or whatnot that uh that
they
got uh ignored and blown off more or
less
um and then if you have like the magical
asian man who wants to give everyone
money
and like who came from the internet then
like i became more of like a figure
in part because like i was more
interesting um
now that this is not something i'm i
think is necessarily
like a super positive in american
like politics you know like i happen to
think both steve bullock and michael
bennett
um uh deserved more attention than they
got
um from voters or from in you know
folks in in the know um
and it's one reason why you have people
suggesting completely
seriously that you know the rock should
run for president
or like someone that we all know trucker
calls
kanye well tucker carlson like you know
on like on the republican side who is
like a commentator entertainer but at
this point the things have kind of
merged where if you have like a very
prominent public persona
then that actually is like a massive
um value add in terms of your political
currency
absolutely and it's scary i mean we
don't quite understand the
kanye west's motivations you know there
are some people who
you know would read uh something into it
about him wanting to split the vote
uh and then other people who think like
no the whole thing is just
a a manic episode and there is no logic
behind it or
or vision he's just having a meltdown
but regardless
they say in certain states when they did
some quick polling maybe he already had
two percent
or four percent and that's what's scary
about the idea of
unqualified people jumping in
because clearly our country has not been
discerning enough
to say i don't think being on the
apprentice is enough
to run the country i don't i don't think
having those bankruptcies and running
hotels makes this person
qualify and so we are scared when we
hear trump's kids are going to run one
day or tucker carlson or
or you know or the rock where you you
think
oh no i i want someone who really
understands how government
works i want somebody who
who has a you know a vision that i agree
with i don't want to just be somebody
who's
popular now it's not impossible that a
famous person
can turn out to be a a a
wise thoughtful good president it's but
man it's that's a
the percentages of that are probably
still pretty scary
pretty low and we see it with donald
trump now his lack of experience means
he doesn't really understand how to work
government he doesn't know
how to get masks made he doesn't know
how to get enough test tubes
so that you could do the testing and he
doesn't want to
he literally doesn't even want to find
out how to do it because
he is lazy he clearly has educational
issues he doesn't think well
and so he says let the governors handle
it because he
can't manage a gigantic bureaucracy
and we need people that know how to do
that you know
what's tough judd is and i i generally
agree with uh with a lot of what you
just said
i'm just so many americans have looked
up and been like man this stuff's not
been working for us and even when you
and i talked about like the good times
of when
al gore was running in 2000 and you made
the caveat which was right it's like
like relatively speaking things were
were good um
at that point even now yeah compared to
now
but we also recognize that like uh that
there's been a lot
there have been a lot of people left
behind even like the relatively good
times these bad times are
showing just how exposed many american
families are
where you know like that like that
there's like uh
just financial insecurity everywhere and
like uh
and many americans have felt excluded
from uh even the
gains that have been made uh and there's
so many americans that just look up and
be like man
like even under the democrats like you
know my
factory was closing my main street
stores were closing because of amazon
like
they look up and they're like not sure
in my opinion that's what one of the
things that fuels
like our interest in these folks from
outside government because like like the
the because people have lost
faith in a lot of things in our society
um
but but like one of the things they've
lost faith in is that if they get
uh like the other party into power in dc
that things will
meaningfully change where like in their
school or on their street or
you know these things now all of that
said i'm obviously
very pro-biden i've endorsed him i've
been uh doing everything i can to help
um and i get the sense from what you've
just said that you are also pulling for
uh team joe the fall
i don't think that's like much of a
stretch um so i would would love to
hear like uh what you're seeing
and also if there are particular races
that you're
um like focused on outside of the big
gahuna
race between joe and donald trump
whether there are some political
candidates that have caught your eye
certainly on our side there are you know
a number of candidates that i'm trying
to help
and elevate like at the local levels um
and was wondering if if there were
uh people that you were working with on
that side well i think that
um you know it's very important that
uh the democrats will win the senate
because
i think you know if you're to envision
what the next four years would be if
if joe biden was the president
we're going to be in the midst of the
pandemic into next year
maybe beyond into 22.
it also might be something that is
around in some form chronically
where it's like the flu in the sense
that we're getting
shots every year and what if the shot
only works 50
of the time i mean the flu shot we all
get it and some years we're like oh they
didn't get the right one this year
so we don't know how many years we're
going to be dealing with this where it's
very
serious hopefully there'll be some sort
of you know
medicines that help us even if we do get
it where it's not as dangerous
we don't know yet but that could play
out over years yes
so we we have to also assume that
that the country will be very impatient
for solutions from the next
president economic solutions for the
disaster that's
clearly coming from all of this
and also the medical issues and
if something really meaningful does not
happen
then joe biden will be a one-term
president
there's a chance he's a one-term
president anyway
maybe another democrat will run after
four years
and so without the senate um
i don't think he'll be able to make
large-scale
meaningful change in the country and be
able to fix a lot of what
we've learned about how badly our
institutions work
i mean we're basically finding out on a
daily basis that on almost any issue
you could take it to the supreme court
it takes years
and you don't actually get solutions uh
you can't even find out if you're
allowed
to if the congress is allowed to
subpoena people
to speak to committees right we're we're
still not sure
if they're allowed to force people to
answer questions to be held accountable
for their work for the country uh and
you could kick the the can down uh the
street on
almost anything in the course right so
the justice system is is
a complete mess the courts are a
complete mess
and my concern is
that things don't turn around and it
goes right back to the republicans in
four years
and what it will be is a smarter donald
trump
a less demented donald trump
with the same long-term
vision i mean donald trump is not a very
efficient
person we don't know what we don't even
know how much of these
choices he makes are his or just the
people around him who are
able to get ideas through this strange
man
you know when i hear that like they're
not going to let they they try to not
let
students stay in the country if their
college switches to zoom classes
i don't think donald trump was in a room
and thought that up
you know that's that is the thing that
many people are concerned about judd is
like
imagine competent and malevolent uh
you know as opposed to yeah and tom
cotton you know you know there's all
these people
uh that are are truly dangerous that it
could swing back to them
very quickly if the country's still
struggling in a few years and you know
what the country will be
struggling and and so what what can a
president who controls the congress and
the senate do in terms of
of health care in terms of
larger changes
[Music]
here at yang speaks we are all about
doing things better
and products of the future and what's
the mattress of the future
it's helix sleep oh my gosh this thing
is custom designed for you you go to the
helix quiz
and then you talk about how firm you
want the mattress
whether you sleep on your side back or
stomach i'll leave it to you to guess
how
andrew yang sleeps but after you take
the quiz you order the mattress it gets
sent to you
you can add sheets or pillows or
whatever you need and
then it arrives it's the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2019
and 2020 by gq and wired magazine
so if you're looking for a mattress and
you like to sleep
who does not like to sleep at this point
sleeping
is a must for a song
go to helixsleep.comyang take their
two-minute sleep quiz they'll match you
with a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life and
they have a 10-year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights
risk-free that's right you can get a new
awesome mattress and sleep on it for 99
days risk-free
and ship that thing back they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but they know you're gonna keep it
because you'll never have slept better
andrew answer this question do you think
you can sleep anywhere
i feel like i've seen you sleep in very
uncomfortable positions on the iowa bus
or in your subaru or
in various campaign vehicles yeah like i
can sleep anywhere
that's true yeah um but i still like a
good mattress
you know i mean oh yeah i don't wake up
with a crick in the neck so helix is
important i just got mine
it's super comfortable it's nice they
also ship it right to your door it's in
this
relatively heavy but compact package so
it's the size of a thimble it's like a
freaking cartoon no i'm kidding
but they're offering two hundred dollars
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
yang that's h e l i x sleep.com
yang for up to two hundred dollars off
and some free pillows
[Applause]
you know i thought you had one of the
best tweets i've ever seen
uh and i'm gonna misquote it but it's
when they did the first stimulus for
this
and your tweet was something like i
guess they did have the money
for health care was it for health care
or for something else
what was the quote well in my case it
was uh it was for
universal basic incomes i guess they did
have the money for
your universal basic income the whole
time right and that's what we learned
which is
all these things that they don't want to
do let's say
forgive some student debt or
to end mass incarceration whatever it is
that we always did have the money we
always do to take care of health care
we have the money to give you know a lot
of cash to casinos
for losing money over the last few
months or or
two yeah we have the billions for that
but we've given
millions i meant trillions yeah yeah we
could have fixed schools for the country
we could have free college
uh you know for a lot of people in this
country so
sadly where my head goes is
you know when you think about it a lot
of this is
a scam you know it's a scam it is
siphoning off money
to people who don't need it and even
when the economy collapses
you know the richest among us they make
money in that even donald trump said he
loved when the economy crashed in 2008
he made a lot of money
buying things up when it was cheap the
stock market is at all time highs
uh you know on in many respects like the
winner take all economies is getting
more extreme
but you're 100 right judd that the work
has to
um has to kick into high gear as soon as
the new president's in place in 2021 and
we don't have
that much time like we have to go huge
and big to try to
rejuvenate revitalize hundreds of
thousands of communities around the
country because if
we fail in this and it's one reason why
you you do need a
somewhat um
unified legislative branch like you hope
that the
democrats and you know like have enough
of a critical mass to get some real
work done get some real bills passed but
we have to
do the work over the next number of
years or else like that this wave does
come
uh crashing back the other way you know
it's like
in a way like i feel like americans
donald trump was like a giant
fu to the system just like screw it like
get the
narcissist reality tv star in there
drain the swamp um i believe that
joe will win and then we'll have a
chance to do the work
uh and we just need everyone to actually
um get on board with like a more active
invigorated
uh effort to revitalize the country that
emanates from the federal government and
i know there are a lot of people who
aren't like huge fans of the government
um like taking a leadership role in a
lot of these things but like we have no
choice i mean you're talking about
like a multi-trillion dollar uh effort
that's needed to
do a lot of the things you just named
you know like uh
overhaul our our totally immoral system
of incarceration
invest in infrastructure and uh
renewable
energy new schools
like you name it like we should be doing
it because we're short millions and
millions
of jobs and the folks who are in their
houses right now figuring out how
they're going to make ends meet
like it's it's heartbreaking like we we
just uh
we just failed i mean like our
government has been
out of touch with the people for so long
and i think that's one reason why
someone like trump won and now we have
to come back from it
absolutely and i think that on some
level after uh
obama there were a lot of people who
said well you were in for eight years
it didn't touch me it didn't get to me
and obviously
you know that administration would say
you know we didn't control
uh yeah there was mitch mcconnell saying
hey let's like obstruct everything in
sight and so they obstructed it
everything and so
you know one point of view is they
accomplished an enormous amount
for having that type of obstruction
uh but it is up to the country
to give the president the power by
controlling
the senate and the congress i mean if
you want anything to happen
you you have to control both to have you
know a real
sea change with the environment i mean
you know here's the scariest part of the
pandemic
what we're learning is that a certain
percentage of the country
is kind of crazy like they won't wear
masks
they're not long-term thinkers you know
to solve the climate issue
i mean if you get someone to wear a mask
how are you going to get somebody to
have solar panels how are you going to
have somebody to
make a choice to switch what kind of car
they drive i mean
it requires hundreds of sacrifices
for everybody to save the planet and
we're
as a country we're not long-term
thinkers people seem to feel like i want
to be as happy as i can be today
i don't want anything to to
inconvenience me
and i will fight you to the death for
that but
if as a country and as a world we're not
in it together
if we're not all making sacrifices if
we're not all trying to lift each other
up
uh we will we definitely will not
survive
i mean when you look at the world and
you know how they
uh have reduced their coping cases and
you look at our country where everyone
feels like they deserve everything all
the time and we can't do it
even today we can't do it well that
can't do spirit is what will
have our cities underwater
in 50 years and that's the saddest part
i mean donald trump clearly didn't ask
anything of the country he could have he
could have gotten on deep and said
as of today here's what i know every one
of you i don't care if you're in the
middle of the woods and no one's around
wear a mask
and we're going to be out of this and
we're going to save a lot of lives
and we're going to get back to work and
he won't say it and he encourages
a certain kind of defiant independence
which will prevent us from solving covet
it'll prevent us from solving
the next pandemic which we also think is
coming is coming yes
and prevent us from solving the the
climate crisis
which we're in the center of right now
no one wants to
talk about it well i think it's one
reason why you and yours are so
important judd is because you're one of
the preeminent storytellers
of this time and like we need ways to
communicate some of these ideas to folks
in america who you know aren't in one
camp or another
uh and i thought your movie king of
staten island actually like helped make
like really important
points that any american would
understand and be excited about around
sacrifice and loyalty like you know from
pete's family which was somewhat
biographical like a lot of it's around
the fire department in
uh staten island uh and you know if you
think about you know like who's pro
fireman i feel like that's everybody
well i i think in a way what the one
reason i wanted the movie to come out
now
uh was because i thought
this is what we're talking about that in
a way
there's a spirit to the firefighting
community that is
selfless you know there are people uh
and we see them in all different
businesses now but
if you just think about firefighters
they get up every day they're going to
get a call
they're going to put themselves in a
dangerous situation to help
you out and they're trying to be there
for the people they work with
you know they're trying to be in the
best shape of their lives so they can
save you
so they could save themselves so they
could save the people that they work
with
and it's all about service right
and i think that you know the
republicans
mock service they mock the idea theory
they're all about service in theory you
know they're all all about like uh
yeah the army and people yeah they like
to talk about the cops in the army but
when you really get down to it
you know they're really more about power
they're
they're not about firefighters
because firefighters are saying
your life is important and i'm going to
spend my life trying to make your life
better and in a way that's what every
citizen in the country
we're all firefighters now at least well
we are because
because the country's on fire absolutely
and and
so it shouldn't be america first or make
america great
it it shouldn't be that when people
don't want to get killed by the cops
that you call them marxists
that's not what it's about you know
that's a that's a signal like oh no
they're marxist
it's about that we all need to help each
other we all need to lift each other
up that's why it's so powerful when you
see uh you know
those mothers the other night in
portland yeah stand up
to this secret police force well it says
everything there
you know those are people clearly there
are people relying on them and they
think it's worth
putting themselves in physical danger to
call out the madness
and to try to stop it and we will not
survive as a species without
we are interconnected you know you could
say make america great but
we have to be in communication with
every country in the world to solve
these problems
yeah yeah i mean how are you going to
fight the next pandemic if you're
not in contact with the governments of
other parts of the the world who are
probably going to be seeing it first
yeah we're quitting the w.h.o
we're getting out of the paris climate
accords
we you know this is the moment where we
should be trying to figure out how to
make
all of these connections work better
and that's what i hope happens with with
joe biden
and then i believe it will judd
you and i are going to be part of the
team that's hopefully helping to knit
the country back together
appreciate the heck out of you i've
enjoyed your work
for decades uh i think you're one of the
most powerful human storytellers
uh in our country today uh and grateful
to you for everything you do as
a fellow parent even though we're just
trying to make things better so that our
kids can inherit
a country in a world that uh you know
we're still proud to leave to them
so thank you man appreciate you thank
you thanks uh for having me out
no problem my pleasure and really if you
haven't seen it or
uh yet king of staten island is a great
great way
to spend a couple of hours particularly
now when we're all like content hungry
we're looking around
it's like uh it's it
it's a beautiful film you know it's like
looking at it was funny
um poignant uh like actually felt
uplifted by it
and obviously judd and pete and everyone
else made the movie before
this time but it actually felt very very
much of this time
well i i'm glad that uh you know people
have liked it
and that it's out there and and
i run out of content as well i'm
watching like season four of american
idol now i'm going back
and i'm watching you know remington
steel
so at least i could offer something new
to the people who haven't seen it yet
so you heard it here first folks if
anyone has any old tv recommendations
just uh pop into judd's twitter thread
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode